the media has been reporting this week
with a certain amount of unsubtle glee
that a huge chunk of americans abandoned
their religion over the last two years
accelerating an already existing trend
this trend is certainly important it's
one of the most important and
consequential things happening in our
world today in fact our society is being
fundamentally reshaped as we speak
but as always the media reports uh tend
to miss the point while also
misinterpreting the data
there is a great religious shift taking
place but i don't think it's accurate to
say that all of these people are leaving
religion necessarily and i'll explain
why but first let's take a look at the
findings
as reported by the wall street journal
it says quote
religious affiliation in the u.s has
continued to fall during the pandemic
according to a new survey from the pew
research center the percentage of
americans who identify as christians now
stands at 63 percent down from 65
percent of 2019 and from 78 78 in 2007.
meanwhile 29 of americans now identify
as having no religion up from 26 in 2019
and 16
in 2007 when pew began tracking
religious identity many places of
worship closed during the pandemic some
voluntarily others as a result of state
and local social distancing rules and
in-person church attendance is roughly
30 to 50 percent lower than it was
before the pandemic
um estimates estimates barna group a
research firm that studies faith in the
us uh
in the u.s millions of americans move to
worshiping online and questions linger
about how many will come back to the
in-person worshiping so let's pause for
a moment to consider two points
first of all these numbers are indeed
truly horrifying if you are a member of
a traditional religion
and if you agree with john adams who
said that our political system was made
only for a moral and religious people
and is wholly inadequate to the
government of any other
you know if you do then this should
trouble you greatly
dropping from 78
christian to 63
in less than 15 years is cataclysmic
even more so when you take a step back
and consider the fuller picture polls of
this kind conducted back say in the
1950s would have found that well over 90
percent of the country was christian
all that's almost everybody
now we're and certainly you know 90
christian
and then the rest would be other
religions
there'd be almost nobody who identified
as non-religious
now we're on track as christians to be a
minority
and that will happen far sooner than you
think i would give it maybe until the
middle of this decade another five years
perhaps
of course we're already a minority and
have been for some time if you take into
account that not every self-identified
christian is really a christian
that's the problem with a survey like
this you know you're not going to find
anyone who self-identifies as
non-christian and yet actually is
christian that doesn't happen the
christian religion is such that if you
think you aren't in it then you aren't
but just because you think you are in it
doesn't mean you are
case in point joe biden if he was
contacted for this survey uh he would
have said yeah i'm christian but he
rejects nearly every moral teaching of
the catholic church and denies its moral
authority and yet would call himself
catholic and thus christian he's not
his claim is at best self-delusion but
probably more likely a conscious lie
all of that to say
um you know let's not engage in
self-delusion ourselves and pretend that
these kinds of survey findings aren't
important or that the situation isn't
really as bad as this makes it seem
it is that bad and in fact it's worse
we were once a christian nation
we are no longer a christian nation
soon we won't even be a majority
christian nation
and as our founders knew
this doesn't work
it's not working the country doesn't
work when it when it is not anchored in
the christian faith
another point church attendance is
perhaps
as it says 50 lower than it was two
years ago
so church has lost half
half of their congregations in the span
of two years
and they're not coming back okay
and this squares with my own anecdotal
experience for what it's worth every
church i've attended over the last year
has been relatively sparse in attendance
i'm not sure i've seen a full church
except on holidays since 2019
and even back then it was somewhat rare
to see a totally full church now you
just never see them
why i mean why have people abandoned
going to church part of it of course is
the decline in traditional religious
religiosity the decline in christian
affiliation generally but the drop-off
for church attendance is far outpacing
the drop in christian affiliation
why is that a big part of the reason for
that is that many churches most i'm
guessing
closed their doors often for months at a
time during the pandemic during a time
when people most needed spiritual
guidance and spiritual formation
and leadership
the church wasn't there
it had it had fled
in the night in fear
now you might rationalize that churches
were forced to do this the government
told them they had to close down the
problem is that many remained closed
even when they no longer had to be
closed and even during the time when
they had to be closed
they can still be faulted for complying
with the with the with these absurdly
unconstitutional edicts
closing down the the right to to the
free uh exercise of religion is right
there in the first amendment
governments coming in and shutting down
churches indefinitely
certainly flies in the face of that
so the government had no moral authority
to shut down any churches
which means the churches had the moral
authority to refuse and say we're not
shutting down you can arrest us all
we're not shutting down
a few churches did that
heroically most did not
most just shut their doors and said okay
you let us know when we can go back to
practicing our religion again
so through this mixture of compliance
and willful cooperation churches sent a
message to the public and the message
was you don't need us
we aren't necessary
you can get along fine without us
and great numbers of people heard that
message and they took it to heart and
now here we are
but there's another very important point
to make about all this but first let's
go back to the article for a minute
it says among the 29 percent who say
they have no religion four percent say
they are theists and five percent
agnostic
most of those figures are unchanged
since 2017.
the percentage of americans who identify
as nothing in particular grew from 16 in
2017 to 20 this year
though some who identify as nothing in
particular may believe in god uh mr
smith said they are far less likely to
pray or attend services than americans
who identify with a religious group
the share of americans who prayed daily
fell to 45 of 2021 compared with 58
in 2007.
it says the secularizing trends that
have been evident for a long time show
no signs of slowing and certainly no
signs of reversing
though protestants remain the largest
group most of the drop in religious
affiliation has come from their ranks
some 40 percent of americans now
identify as protestant compared with 43
in 2019 and 52 in 2007.
okay now to the important point
what we're witnessing is not really a
decline in religion per se at least not
at least the decline is not is not
nearly as steep as those numbers make it
seem
because many of the non-religious people
have not given up on religion or left
religion
they have just in fact changed religions
this is a religious shift
not a drop
and to understand this we have to take a
step back i think and consider what we
even mean when we say the word religion
what is a religion
most dictionary definitions will tell
you that a religion is you know a belief
in some kind of supernatural entity with
associated rituals and customs attached
to that belief
and that is one form that religion takes
yes
most of the ancient religions
the traditional religions take exactly
that form
but i think i prefer a broader
definition that helps to make sense of
what we're seeing in our culture today
i would say that religion can be defined
as simply a shared sense
of transcendent meaning and it has to be
shared because religion by definition
cannot be a totally individualized
pursuit if it is then it's just a belief
not a religion
and then there has to be that sense of
transcendence or else it's not a
religion it's a social club
to be in a religion is to look towards
something transcendent something beyond
ordinary physical experience
and to be standing alongside others who
are looking in the same direction as you
now this means again that some of those
self-described christians aren't really
christian at all aren't really religious
at all
because when you go to some churches
today there is no sense of anything
transcendent at all
everything is earthbound
all of the focus is on earthly
priorities and values
i mean you can go to some so-called
churches today and not even see a cross
anywhere in the building
because the cross
is transcendence
and in these churches they don't want
you looking to anything transcendent
and the people in those churches they're
not attending a church they're attending
a motivational seminar
or maybe a book club
in fact many christian churches have
taken great pains over the decades to
deliberately turn away from the
transcendent and the mystical and to
make the church-going experience far
more sterile and sanitized in that way
which is another reason why fewer people
are going to church because you've
removed the very thing that motivated
them to come in the first place
but what about all those self-described
non-religious people
those allegedly non-religious people
well a good portion of them are leftists
not all but a good portion
and leftism is a religion in itself
it may not have all of the same
structured customs and traditions part
of what defines it is its hostility to
customs and traditions
its tradition is to destroy tradition
religious people of the past you know
built statues and monuments members of
the leftist religion tear down statues
and monuments
but even so it is a religion
and this becomes quite obvious when you
consider critical race theory
the belief in inherited racial guilt
inherited racial persecution
gender theory the belief that people can
be born in the wrong bodies
the belief that a man can be a man and
yet somehow still in some way be a woman
at the same time
all of the pronouns and the new gender
labels and so on none of this is
scientific
it certainly isn't
logical
there's no empirical basis to any of
this
they cannot locate the source of white
guilt or black victimization
or
a man's womanhood anywhere on earth
this is their version of grasping for
transcendent meaning
there's a reason why they hold that
prefix trans in such high regard
they put it all the way at the top of
the
pyramid because that's really what they
mean when they call a man a trans woman
they mean that he is a transcendent
woman
his womanhood transcends physical
boundaries making him in many ways a
more spectacular specimen of womanhood
than a biological woman
that's how a man won woman of the year a
few years ago
their ideas about race gender victimhood
justice fairness equity tolerance all of
these ideas have a religious
supernatural transcendent quality to
them and to call it transcendent by the
way is not an endorsement
transcendent just means that something
is beyond the range of normal human
experience psychosis is a transcendent
experience too in a certain way
there is transcendence that points you
to truth and beauty
which is christian transcendence
and then there is the religion of
leftism
which is a religion but one that directs
you towards confusion
and insanity
um
you know the idea of christian
transcendence is you're looking beyond
the physical you're looking beyond your
immediate experiences
and then anchoring yourself to something
beyond it but something that's even more
real
something sturdier
with the leftist transcendence you're
looking beyond physical experience
and uh just going out there into space
and floating around not anchored to
anything untethered unmoored
that's what we're witnessing in our
culture today
it's not the death of religion but the
birth of a new one
an anti-religion religion but a religion
all the same
one with its own supernatural beliefs
its own heresies
its own anti-tradition traditions
its own ideas about sin its own
inquisitions
human beings as we discover are
religious by nature
you're never going to have a totally
non-religious society it can't happen
there will always be religion the only
question is if we choose a true religion
or a false
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated